you can try many many other variations
depending on where to put the rubber
bands and also using more paper clips
let me show you under two examples we
have tried the position number one
position number two but one position
that we have never tried this is quite
interesting rap band in the middle and
it has to stay on the paper and you can
put the bag paper clips and see what
happens
rubber band now in the middle here and
paper clips at the top so now what's
going to happen when I pull this is what
happens so rap band is hanging from the
paper bond that's okay but those two
paper clips got linked against each
other but each one of them is linked
with the rubber band so they're all
three if you like three circles a
meeting in the middle and any two of
them being no poor man it's not boring
because even if I make for example the
rubber band disappear the two paper
clips is linked and so you can probably
yes at this stage what's going to happen
if I put the rubber band in the same
position that one paper clip at the top
at the other paper clip at the bottom so
paper clips are on the wrong size of
each other so now what's going to happen
when I pull do you know I guess
interesting let's talk that's into looks
like the previous one but this time each
paper clips is linked with our band but
not between themselves let's finish with
something that is working progress so
far we have been linking paper clips
together and sometimes we refer to this
as addition I mean in order to paper
clips coming together so it's like
adding what about subtracting by which I
mean can we start from two paper clips
that are linked all already and slotting
them in some configuration on a bent
paper can you take them apart now I
tried many many different possibilities
and it turns out that this time the
orientation matters you know you can
link paper clips in many many different
ways for example you can link them here
or you can link them for example here or
you can link them here and so on so the
position matters and also you know you
can lick them like this or you can turn
the paper clip around and you can link
them right like this it's very very
confusing so let's try to link them
here and see how we fare it turns out
that this kind of link will end up
tearing the paper and just distorting
the paper clips and it ends up in
disaster also I think because you see I
haven't done this many times so I have
to be very careful each time but if I
change the orientation of the paper
clips and put them in this configuration
that's the right configuration you may
not see much of a difference but the key
is how those are linked at the top let's
do it very very carefully those two
paper clips already linked I bend the
paper
in that standard position but I swapped
the paper clip here and here by allowing
this linked pair to straddle over the
paper like so here and here like this
okay and then I swap them very carefully
and here is the preparation paper clips
were linked now I pull the ends and
hopefully this works if it doesn't we'll
be very sad and something some disaster
happens okay let's see we'll be able to
do it they came apart so we can now
subtract you like that yeah no that's
very nice they come up you can make them
come apart yeah computation or
calculation in general we always think
naturally because that's how we learn
these things in school and about numbers
calculate even numbers all perhaps at
the more advanced level calculating with
formulas and you know you do some
algorithm you do some recipe and then
the expected results come out but here
your brain although it hasn't formalized
anything he hasn't written a number so
all formulas has effectively computed